what is the next story all right well
this is exciting movie news we have our
first trailer for scream five now who
was in the first screen oh that's right
you you were drew barrymore
uh-huh
whatever his link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
now
screen 5 doesn't come out until january
14th but they say it's going to be worth
the wait the original cast is backed
except for
you
um well because if you haven't seen it
spoiler alert
um
i don't watch that many scary movies but
i'm gonna go to this one because i just
watched the first one because you're in
it and you're really good in it by the
way uh you're really right oh really
good
[Applause]
i took it as such
an acting challenge i read kevin um
williamson's script and i was it was
called scary movie at the time not
scream which ended up ironically being
the parodies name
and i just thought god you know what
sucks about scary movies is
you always know that main person's gonna
make it like by the skin of their teeth
what if we took that out
i die and all bets are off and then it
just took off into this wonderful genre
of a of a
of us horror film it was funny it was
irreverent it was interesting
um and uh this is the first time i've
been like damn i wish i wasn't dead i
want to be in this bed
i i love the way that they've actually
made it genuinely scary and
i think it's going to be a big deal i do
i remember after seeing that movie when
i go home at night that is the reason
that i do not linger in the downstairs
area that i go straight to my bedroom
and i shut the door because if there's
anyone around i just want to sleep
through it you know what i mean yes if
there's an intruder or an attacker i
want to be out cold when that happens
yeah i don't want to fight i don't want
to chase anybody around my house with a
knife or anything like that no i'm good
yeah i'm good i was also upset that the
popcorn got burnt that really bugged me
i want to talk to you about that are you
a fan of scary movies i i don't no i
mean that that i watch also because drew
was in it um but i don't like scary
movie i don't like violence i don't mind
being scared but i don't like gory
violence no you know that's not i'm not
down with that no i like steel magnolias
that's like it for me in terms of
like the scene with the orange juice
that freaked me out uh no more nothing
passed out still ignorant drink your
juice she'll be drinking don't talk
about me like i'm not here remember
okay chelsea it's your next story okay
i'm gonna do a new story it has been two
years since the horror of cats the movie
and andrew lloyd webber is still
traumatized by what hollywood did to his
musical so people is reporting the
famous broadway composer recently
revealed he had to get an emotional
support animal
after seeing the movie cats yes andrew
said when he saw the movie all he
thought was oh god no
well a that's a very special review that
you know cats had to be that bad if
someone this gay refused to see it you
know it
the reviews were so unbelievable
did you see it i did not see it i heard
about it i'm not really into cats to
begin with so it wasn't really hard for
me not to see that movie but i heard how
horrible it was what what was so bad
about it you know what i wish now that i
would have seen it so i could talk to
you about how truly bad it was who was
in it do we know i can run that down
taylor swift was in it jennifer hudson
was in it dame judy dench was in it yet
think it'd be good right
yeah what's she doing in a bad movie
dame judy dent she's never been in
anything bad no but now she has dame
yeah also why were people so mad about
it is it did everyone hold cats that
dearly like what is the deal i think
cats was a lot of people's very first
broadway experience and i think that
because i know it was my first broadway
play so it was barnum and bailey and
then cats i never saw cats because i
hadn't such a deep dive into my
childhood but i my neighbor had a cat
that was really mean so cats have always
scared me so i never wanted to see the
musical because i thought it would bring
back childhood trauma but
cats aren't that friendly though i mean
they have that reputation for a reason
you know there's no warm fuzzies going
on huh no
i never have one
yeah well anyway um
so uh chelsea um you know you love to
stir things up on the internet so
chelsea put out these debates on
instagram and online it was do you do
your toilet paper under or over
uh-huh um raise of hands who's in over
raise your hands if you're an under
okay we are animals apparently
and then show this towel picture because
i participated in this too and like the
biggest movie stars on the planet
participated in this uh raise your hand
if you're a one
raise your hand if you're a two
okay that's then three
oh you okay three looks like you're
living in a spa
right
congrats on your life if you're a three
literally what is wrong with me i am an
under and a and a sad folder what what's
wrong with me these are such this is i
didn't know that i was i know i don't
think a lot of people knew until it was
put in front of them and then people
went nuts about it so yeah it is a very
it's a it's very divisive yes it is i
mean you had like the biggest stars in
hollywood chiming in about how they're
an over or and under or a towel folder
anyway when it's over i feel like it
just never ends and you waste toilet
paper yeah
under puts a stop gap well what sparked
the conversation is you know in airports
the toilet paper how you grab a piece
and one piece and it rips off like that
makes me upset because no one needs just
one piece no you know a piece even like
a thing yeah i feel like it's like just
a pin and you have to pull it and you're
like that puts us all in a bad situation
right because you want to leave the
restroom nice for the next person who
comes along obviously yeah so they
should be allowing us to get some more
toilet paper so that's the first thing
that they need to fix is the airports
you should run for office i'm just
saying you just earned my vote thank you
but maybe
hold on i think i think we might have
found another debate like
here's a question i have if you see the
role is empty
at someone's house or in a public space
do you change it always
common courtesy who else anybody yeah
and who's not raising their hands
interesting
let's all work together okay
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you